John Titor claims to be a time traveler
from the Year 2036 and his time machine
kind of looks like a certain DeLorean
whose parts you can actually buy Vsauce
Kevin here this is Milo
time travel edition this is a real time
machine sort of dr. Ronald Mallett time
machine is a spiral of incredibly
powerful lasers and he wishes to send a
particle down and on a spacetime
altering ride into the past
unfortunately it hasn't worked out yet
and no visitors from the future have
arrived Isaac Newton thought time was
like an arrow flying in a straight line
Albert Einstein whoever thought of it
like a river flowing around stars
speeding up and slowing down in fact he
theorized the rate at which time passes
depends on how fast you're going
so someone orbiting the Earth and the
speed of light would actually alter
time-space and when they return to Earth
they will be in the future his theory
was right satellites orbiting the Earth
actually have to alter their clocks to
synchronize with earth time because of
this scientific fact check out this
clock example hold still and the clock
ticks at a normal pace move the clock
and a ticks take longer therefore if you
were in a ship aboard the green orb your
space time would be different from the
time of the guy holding the clock
unfortunately we can't go nearly fast
enough in spaceships to make a
noticeable time change but we could hop
a ride on the blackhole Express spitting
us at incredible speeds like this coffee
spins this beam we'd surely end up in a
different time but no one seems to have
a black hole handy
so instead Stephen Hawking has worms
wormholes to be exact
these are tunnels connecting massive
distances by bending space-time like two
holes on a piece of paper being folded
together wormholes exist in a teeny tiny
play is called quantum foam and we have
no idea how to enlarge them enough for a
human to pass through let alone a TARDIS
the grandfather paradox arises when you
travel into the past and kill your
grandfather thereby never being born and
never being able to travel into the past
to kill your grandmother
David Deutsch believes parallel
universes exist so you could go back in
time for
alternate world without affecting the
one you came from in which case you can
go back and shoot a dinosaur in the face
and your grandpa will be fine
finally to check out an iconic
time-traveling show watch the new season
premiere of Doctor Who Saturday April
23rd at 9:00 8:00 central on BBC America
I'm gonna leave you with a riddle
I'm the beginning of the end and the end
of time and space
I'm essential to creation and I surround
every place what am i leave your answer
in the comments below and we're going to
do the genius of the week a little
differently this time what would you do
if you had a time machine send us a
video response with the tag if I had a
time machine and the person with the
best answer will be our genius of the
week and you can check out everyone's
stories at Time Machine tales comm so
good luck and as always thanks for
watching